speaking of trump and Twitter and social
media it turns out Trump is actually
wanting to get back on Facebook and
start tweeting on Twitter of course his
cap his account has been brought back on
Twitter but uh he has not tweeted yet
and he's also lobbying to get back on
Facebook here from NBC News mounting a
comeback for the White House Donald
Trump is looking to regain control
over as powerful social media accounts
with access to his Twitter account back
Trump's campaign is formerly petitioning
Facebook's parent company to unblock his
account thereafter it was locked in
response to the U.S Capitol Riot two
years ago quote Trump is probably coming
back to Twitter it's just a question of
how and when Senate Republican who spoke
on a condition of anonymity to discuss
private conversations with Trump about
returning to the platform he's been
talking about it for weeks but Trump
speaks for Trump so it's anyone's guess
what he'll do or say or win another
Trump Confidant who also didn't want to
be identified speaking about
conversations with him said that Trump
has sought input for weeks about hopping
back on Twitter and that his campaign
advisors have also workshopped ideas
for his first tweet and then Facebook
has not given a direct answer yet but it
seems likely that they might let him
back on and so he shortly could be
active on Twitter and Facebook once
again here's a bit of this being
discussed
um on CNN former president Donald
Trump's campaign petitioning Facebook to
unblock his account that of course
remember the social media giant locked
in response to the January 6th arrive at
the Capitol let's bring in CNN's Kristen
home she's following this story for us
Kristen tell us more so John as we know
Facebook's ban was not indefinite and as
we reported last week The Meta the
parent group was already having meetings
deliberating whether or not they were
going to let former president Trump back
on its site in fact they were taking it
so seriously they had a small working
group within the company that was
working on that but now it appears that
the campaign is trying to accelerate
that process they sent a letter to Metta
asking for Trump to be reinstated and to
have a meeting with that parent company
now I want to read you one expert
excerpt of why they say they think that
they should be reinstated it says Donald
J Trump is a declared candidate for
president of the United States we
believe the ban on President Trump's
account on Facebook has dramatically
distorted and inhibited the public
discourse moreover every day that
President Trump's political voice
remains silenced furthers an
inappropriate interference in the
American political and election process
so why does this matter well if you kept
up with politics pre and post Trump's
social media bands you remember the
significant nature of how that affected
his ability to use his megaphone use his
voice to craft and influence the public
discourse the daily conversations and
yeah now he's on true social and he
occasionally says stuff or he's
constantly saying stuff we occasionally
cover it but it's not the same as what
he had his voices on Twitter and
Facebook but Twitter most significantly
and so whether or not he starts tweeting
again
whether or not Facebook allows them back
on will actually affect the next two
years and the voice that he has in his
presidential campaign and uh how he's
able to leverage that in different ways
in a very significant way and so it's
fascinating to watch it's weird and
strange to try to understand why now it
makes sense if
the past actions they got banned for
didn't change why now it makes sense to
bring them back who knows but it seems
likely that will indeed occur and we
will continue to keep up with it follow
me on Twitter Luke P Beasley
you know I have a very acute Newfound
appreciation for how busy being a new
parent makes you if you have a little
one at home like me here's something
really easy you can do to simplify your
life our sponsor little spoon is your
One-Stop shop for healthy easy meal time
and snack time for your baby toddler or
big kid delivered right to your door
little spoon delivers fresh organic baby
food which comes in single ingredient
varieties or multi-textured purees
little spoon is meals for toddlers and
big kids they're free of junk and taste
great even the pickiest eaters love them
I've even tried many of them myself they
really are great having healthy snack
time is so easy with little spoons
organic smoothies which come in
convenient pouches in great flavors like
strawberry banana shake purple carrot
acai I love purple carrots I'm gonna
admit that my girlfriend and I have had
a great experience with our little spoon
subscription it just makes life easier
anything to reduce the chaos is a great
thing little spoon is giving my audience
50 off your first order go to
littlespoon.com and use code Pacman 50
off all one word the info is down below